well you should be afraid of taking
risks and pursuing something meaningful
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are if it's making you
miserable
it's on you the problem with being okay
the way you are is that you don't have a
goal then and people need to have a goal
in order to to come to terms with their
life
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world in two
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits need
motivation watch your top 10 with the
leave nation what's that believe nation
it's heaven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack on chewing
today's lessons from a man who went from
being introduced to George Orwell's
writings at a young age to becoming a
Harvard professor writing hundreds
scientific papers and becoming one of
YouTube's latest internet sensations
he's Jordan B Peterson and here's my
take on his top ten rules a success
volume for joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one my personal favorite pursue what is
meaningful you write in the book there
is no faith and no courage and no
sacrifice in doing what is expedient
what do you say to those viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and are locked
into their careers because they are too
afraid to take risks and pursue
something meaningful well the first
thing I would say is well you should be
afraid of taking risks and pursuing
something meaningful but you should be
more afraid of staying where you are if
it's making you miserable it's like the
first thing you want to do is dispense
with the idea that you get to have any
any permanent security outside of your
ability to contend and adapt it's the
same issue with children it's like
you're paying a price by sitting there
being miserable and you might say well
the devil I know is better than the one
I don't it's like don't be so sure of
that
the clock is ticking yeah and if you're
miserable in your job now and you change
nothing in five years you'll be much
more miserable and you'll be a lot older
but this into the luxury to pursue what
is meaningful our viewers have mortgages
they have children yeah they have
payments and loans it's a luxury to
pursue because we lack the resources
well I don't think I don't remember now
I'm not talking about what makes you
happy it's a luxury to pursue what makes
you happy it's a moral obligation to
pursue what you find meaningful and that
doesn't mean it's easy it might require
sacrifice if you need to change your job
to let's say you have family and and and
and children and a mortgage you have
responsibilities you've already picked
up those responsibilities you don't just
get to walk away scot-free and say well
I don't like my job I quit
that's no strategy but what you might
have to do is you think well this job is
killing my soul all right so what do I
have to do about that well I have to
look for another job well no one wants
to hire me it's like okay maybe you need
to educate yourself more maybe you need
to update your your curriculum vitae
your resume maybe you need to overcome
your fear of being interviewed maybe you
need to sharpen your social skills like
you you have to think about these things
strategically if you're
to switch careers you have to do it like
an intelligent responsible person that
might take you a couple of years of
effort to do properly I've dealt with
hundreds of people in my clinical and
consulting practice and we set a goal we
develop a vision and work towards it and
it things inevitably get better for
people so it's not a luxury it's it's
difficult it's a moral responsibility
and it isn't happiness it's it's not the
pursuit isn't for happiness it's a moral
responsibility to push you what is
meaning absolutely rule number two fight
for your beliefs
the first way in which you captured the
world's attention was that University
and that's what I want to talk about now
because the c16 law in Canada was being
proposed contextualized for us what it
is precisely that you were being that
you were opposed to in that well bill
c16 purported to do nothing but extend
human rights provisions to an excluded
group let's say to the transgender and
non gender binary types and and that was
the federal legislation it also made it
a hate crime to to to discriminate or
harass essentially so now then the
question is well what exactly do you
mean by discriminator harass and why
exactly is that a hate crime under the
Criminal Code well there was an answer
to that the answer was well this bill
will be interpreted in light of the
policies generated by the Ontario Human
Rights Commission very large set of
policies now the Ontario Human Rights
Commission is a radically leftist
organization I think it's the most
dangerous organization in Canada
although you could debate that and they
said are all sorts of policies about how
this these LED this legislation was
going to be interpreted and the federal
government linked to their website to
state that bill 16 c 16 would be
interpreted in light of those guidelines
so i went and read all the policies well
one of the policies was that if you
didn't use the preferred pronouns of a
given group that you could be charged
essentially with a hate crime and i
thought no that group is that you can
talk about transgender people yeah and
so there's all these pronouns that have
come up there's 70 different sets of
pronouns approximately to to
hypothetically describe people who don't
fit anywhere on the gender spectrum
which is also something that I don't
really
I don't understand that conceptually
like okay so now I'm comin is compelled
under Canadian law to use the pronoun of
another individuals choice pipe on pain
of law and I thought well no that's not
acceptable it's one thing to put limits
on what a person can't say like say with
hate speech laws which I also don't
agree with by the way but that's a
different argument I think it's a
narrower argument but to compel me to
use a certain content when I'm
formulating my thoughts or my actions
under threat of legislative action I
thought no what's happened there is the
government has introduced compelled
speech legislation into the private
sphere it's never happened in the
history of English common law and so I
said there's no way I'm abiding by that
I don't care what your damn rationale is
we're compassionate it's like no you're
not no you're not you're playing this
radical collectivist left-wing game
you're trying to gain linguistic you're
trying to gain linguistic supremacy in
the in the area of public discourse
you're doing that using compassion as a
guise and you're pulling the wool over
people's eyes and you're not going to do
it with me rule number three take on
challenges we're built for struggle as
human beings you know you're not after
the bubbles of bliss that Dostoyevsky
described in in notes from underground
we're built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want a challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because the
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so and I'm not
saying that in a naive way I know
perfectly well what happens to people
you know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later you're dead and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point but that's not the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and
ten and you develop by contending and
you minimize the net amount of suffering
in the world and that's something man
that's something to do rule number four
don't compare yourself to others rule
four compare yourself to who you were
yesterday and not to who someone else is
today because if you're comparing
yourself to someone else I mean first of
all you don't know very much about the
life of the person you're comparing
yourself to you don't know innit
you know what across all of its
dimensions and second people are very
different and so comparing yourself to
someone else it's it's kind of useful I
guess when you're young but as you get
older and more singular and more
particularly it becomes increasingly
less useful better to compare yourself
to a previous version of yourself and
work for improvement in that way rule
number five develop resilience life is
difficult and you cannot protect your
children what you can do is prepare them
and you can prepare them to be strong
and courageous and truthful and
resilient and reciprocal in their
interactions with other people and that
means you equip them for what life will
be which is at minimum a series of
difficult challenges and and often more
than that because of course people go
through very difficult times in their
lives and a resilient person is capable
of standing up to things in the face of
fear and moving forward voluntarily
convinced of their own competence and
ability to prevail and so the primary
your primary goal as a parent apart from
facilitating your child's social
desirability which is a major obligation
on your part is to encourage your
children and to and I mean that
literally to instill in them a sense of
courage in the face of the difficulties
of life and not to protect them from
that we don't even want to be protected
from those difficulties because a major
part of life and its meaning is the the
challenge that comes with confronting
difficulties rule number six get your
act together I said with Bill c16 that I
wouldn't speak the language of the
radical leftist because I don't think
that that language should define the
game
but let's say it does so here's the game
the world is a battleground of groups
and the they're battling for power
that's it that's the game and some of
them win and they oppress those who
don't win so that's how we're gonna view
the world
okay now the left is say okay well
here's the oppressed people the
oppressors the patriarchy type
patriarchal types they should be ashamed
of themselves and give up some power the
right-wingers the radical right wingers
look at that and they say oh I see so
the game is ethnic identity is it its
identity politics okay we're white males
we're not gonna lose that's the right
wing version of identity politics it's
like screw you if we're gonna divide
into groups if we're gonna divide into
tribes and I'm in my tribe I'm not gonna
get all guilty and lose I'm gonna get
all cruel and win and that's like then
you think well there's people in the
middle they're kind of looking back and
forth which side of the identity
politics spectrum I am I going to fall
in do I want to go with do I want to go
do I want to be driven primarily by
compassion and I'm am I going to accept
guilt for my historical privilege so
that's one possibility and then I'm the
oppressor I'm the member of the
oppressor group or am I gonna say Oh to
hell with that I'm just gonna play the
wind well then I'm gonna go to the right
it's like well my sense is how about we
don't play either of those games and the
reason we shouldn't play them is well
the Soviets played the left wing game
and like killed who knows how many tens
of millions of people you can't even
count it accurately the estimates range
from twenty to a hundred million those
are pretty big error bars and that in
the Maoists maybe a hundred million
certainly 60 million so okay that didn't
work out so well and then there's the
Nazis like they played ethnic identity
politics and racial superiority it's
like what do we want to play that game
see what I'd been trying to do really
what I've been trying to do for the last
30 years is say look there's heavy
temptations to play those sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together stand up in the world make
something of yourself stay away from the
ideological oversimplifications
set your house in order that's rule 6 in
the in this book so I have a book rule
in there says set your house in perfect
order before you criticize the world and
it's a very dark chapter about the
motivations of the Columbine High School
killers and this other guy named carl
panzram who is a serial rapist and
arsonist and murderer and these he wrote
an autobiography and the Columbine kids
also wrote about why they did what they
did they're resentful to the core bitter
bitter resentful terrible and well I'm
suggesting that people stay away from
that resentment resentfulness and
bitterness even though life is hard and
there's malevolence in the world it's
like yeah you can you can tell a story
where everyone's a victim because we all
die we all get sick you know and and and
things happen to us that are bitter and
terrible betrayal deceit lies like
people hurt us on purpose you know so
it's not just the tragedy of life it's
malevolence as well it's everyone's a
victim you can tell that story the
problem is if you tell that story you
start to act it out you make all of that
worse that's the problem and it's so
this is why partly I got attracted to
Christian imagery at least in part
because there's an idea in Christianity
that you should pick up your goddamn
cross and like walk up the hill and
that's dramatically that's correct
that's the right answer it's like you've
got a heavy load of suffering to bear
and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust it's what are you gonna do about
it
accept it voluntarily and try to
transform as a consequence that's the
right answer
it's the right answer because the rest
of it is tribalism and we're we're too
technologically powerful to get all
tribal again rule number seven
concentrate on who you could be people
have an unspecified potential for
development educationally obviously with
regards to the skills they have but also
in relationship to their character and
it's it's much it's much more
encouraging for people I think to
concentrate on who they could be rather
than who they are especially when
they're young because they still have
most of their life ahead of them and and
they're not everything they could be yet
and so to tell people even something
like well you should feel good about
yourself
the way you are is like well that
there's something there that's seriously
lacking because there's so much more
that you could be that you need to be
and that you should be aiming at the Sun
you're the problem with being okay the
way you are is that you don't have a
goal then and people need to have a goal
in order to to come to terms with their
life rule number eight get out of your
comfort zone
now this baboon here who's supposed to
be basically just a fool when the story
was first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and
they so he represents the self from the
Union perspective now the self is
everything you could be across time so
you imagine that there's you and there's
the potential inside you whatever that
is you know and potential is an
interesting idea because it's represents
something that isn't yet real yet we act
like it's real because people will say
to you you should live up to your
potential and that potential is partly
what you could be if you interacted with
the world in a manner that would gain
you the most information right because
you build yourself out of the
information in the piagetian sense but
it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
jeans turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world in two
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
central and that would be say like the
rock in the Pride Rock and the Lion King
because you take yourself out of your
dopey little village and that's just a
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
you're becoming informed which means
information' it means you're becoming
more organized at every level of
analysis but there's also more of you
too rule number nine find your why by
primary motive as a clinical
psychologist and educator is to help
individuals live more meaningful and
productive lives in harmony with their
families and their community that's my
motive and the evidence for that I think
is well if people go online and first of
all you can watch the lectures and
decide for yourself but you can also go
there's I suspect probably maybe 250,000
people have commented on the lectures
and their effects on them and so that's
what people say I'm watching the
lectures yeah I'm trying to develop a
vision for my life I'm trying to become
more responsible and it's really helping
and that's and that's what I hear all
the time when I do these public lectures
which aren't political but when we gain
success we raise the bar we set our
ambitions higher I mean what is your end
game what do you want that's all that's
what I want I want I want to help as
many individuals as possible become more
courageous more truthful and more
engaged in the pursuit of individual
familial and social harmony that's what
I want and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is pick
the lesser risk you're doing a great job
of modeling courage in the face of farm
well there's something I'd like to say
maybe in closing about courage people
say that to me and you know I don't
think it's exactly right doesn't there's
a line in the Old Testament the fear of
God is the beginning of wisdom and I
think it's more like that it's not that
I'm courageous it's that I'm afraid of
the right things so when I made my
videos it wasn't like that didn't make
me nervous but I was less nervous about
going back to bed and not saying what I
had to say that I was about making the
videos because I know where this is
going I don't want to go there and so
it's it's not so much courage it's that
it's a matter of I it's it's it's less
risky to say something
than to remain silent when you know
there's something to be said I know that
to be the case and so lots of times in
life it's like there's no pathway
forward that's going to shield you from
risk you get to pick this risk or you
get to pick this risk and I think I
picked the lesser risk and that might be
wise but I'm not so sure it's courageous
now I've got a really special bonus
jordan peterson clip around having
humility that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that I want to know question
of the day which clip which message
resonated more with you have resilience
or find your why let me know in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
oh yes chapter 9 is assumed that the
person you are listening to might know
something you don't this is a chapter
about conversation and about the
different forms conversation takes and
so chapter about humility and it's a
chapter about listening and humility
element is it took me a long time to
understand why there's religious
injunctions supporting humility but even
understand what the word really meant
and that sort of technical sense and it
means something like this it means what
you don't know is more important than
what you know and that's a lovely thing
too
then then what you don't know can start
to be your friend you see people are
very defensive about what they know and
for the reasons we've already discussed
but the thing is you don't know enough
and the Riu can tell you don't know
enough because your life is not what it
could be and neither is the life of the
people around you you just don't know
enough and so what that means is that
every time you encounter some evidence
that you're ignorant someone points it
out you should be happy about that
because you think oh you just told me
how I'm wrong it's like great like maybe
I had to sift through a lot of nonsense
to get through the real message that
you're telling me but if you could
actually tell me some way that I'm wrong
and then maybe give me a hint about how
to not be wrong like that well then I
wouldn't have to be wrong like that
anymore that that would be a good thing
and you can you can you can embark on
that adventure by listening to people
and if you listen to people they will
tell you they'll tell you amazing things
if you listen to them and many of those
things are little tools that you can put
in your toolkit like Batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often and so the
humility element is well do you want to
be right or do you want to be learning
and it's deeper than that it's do you
want to be that the tyrannical king
who's already got everything figured out
or do you want to be the continually
transforming hero or fool for that
matter who's getting better all the time
and that's actually a choice you know
it's a deep choice and it's better to be
the self transforming fool who's humble
enough to make friends with what he or
she doesn't know and to listen when
people talk and listening is a
transformative exercise
like if if you listen to the people in
your life for example if you actually
listen to them they'll tell you what's
wrong with them and how to fix it and
what they want they can't even help it
if you start listening because people
are so shocked if you actually listen to
them that they tell you all those sorts
of things that they might not have even
intended to things they don't even know
and then you can you can work with that
if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like I am Tulsa what
a wail out of a handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty-four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for two hundred fifty
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and five minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access